I accept your nomination for President
of the United States in a tight race
Obama and the Democrats are going to
need every vote they can muster so maybe
the party of stimulus spending
dodd-frank and the broccoli mandate are
willing to turn libertarian this time
around here are three ways Obama might
win at least some of the ten to fifteen
percent of libertarian minded voters who
believe in shrinking the size and scope
of the federal government candidate
Obama promised the most transparent
administration in history but he's
delivered the exact opposite he also
promised to rein in abuses of executive
power but for God's sake he's even got a
top secret kill list that apparently
includes US citizens on it come clean
Obama starting right now Obama used to
say the war on drugs was failed policy
but since becoming president he's rated
a record number of medical marijuana
dispensaries that are legal under
California law and he's given no
indications that will change his
policies in a second term as a former
heavy user of pot Obama is in the
perfect position to push for an end to a
drug war that he knows is awful Obama
and the Democrats are supposed to be the
party of doves right yet the president
tripled troops in Afghanistan and things
are not any better there he unilaterally
entered Libya and he's put troops in
Uganda for God's sake this guy won the
Nobel Peace Prize how about coming up
with a foreign policy that makes sense
and leads to a serious reduction in
defense spending which is up over
seventy percent in real terms in the
21st century Obama's economic and
regulatory policies have irradiated him
with most libertarians but there's still
little love loss for the GOP but if
Obama and the Democrats explicitly move
libertarian on some issues yeah anything
could happen for a reason TV I'm Nick
the last name
you